the notion of feeling force is a very
prevalent one in physics velocity is
subjective we are told but acceleration
is real because matter feels force but
what does it mean to actually feel a
force is it something that applies only
to people and conscious observers or is
it experienced by all substance in the
universe indeed the vagueness of the
ward field begs the question is the idea
of feeling force even accurate or is how
we understand one of the most central
concepts and physics fundamentally wrong
[Music]
this is dialogue with can you feel force
[Music]
if you're studying physics it won't be
long before you come across a statement
that goes something like this as an
observer you won't be able to tell if
you're moving at a constant speed or not
but you can tell whether you're
accelerating because you can feel a
force this statement is in reference to
scenarios such as being in a windowless
trainer car and not being able to tell
what speed you're going but being able
to feel acceleration or D acceleration
as you're pushed or pulled about your
seat it makes sense in an everyday
context because we as living organisms
can feel certain forces most prominently
through our sense of weight which is a
register of the normal force of the
earth and other materials pushing
against us but this statement is also
used to justify why acceleration is a
privileged state of motion not just for
conscious observers but for all matter
and content in the universe so if you're
an astute thinker such a statement will
seriously make you scratch your head you
might wonder what exactly is meant by
the word feel since it is a biological
term that applies to the sensory
functions of living organisms
after all forces aren't just experienced
by people but by every type of physical
object in the universe and indeed if we
ask how precisely the presence of a
force is felt or discerned we are going
to come across some major issues even if
we rule out the most literal
interpretation of feeling force that is
via nervous systems and all that an
ambiguity in the concept still remains
an ambiguity which as it turns out is
not just a reflection of our poor choice
in terminology but rather a reflection
of our fundamental ignorant of the
nature of force itself the problem is
this force is not an observable it is
not something you can directly measure
like a time interval or a spatial
displacement it is a hypothetical
construct that takes to measurable
empirical quantities mass and
acceleration and associates them via a
mathematical framework
that means while we can directly see
things like acceleration and motion we
can never see force rather we can only
deduce its presence by applying Newton's
laws this is an important point so let's
make sure to clarify it consider that
you're on a train at a train station
with another train on the next platform
over and suddenly your train begins to
move if like many modern trains it
accelerates smoothly enough he might
become confused about whether it is your
train or the adjacent train that is in
motion this is a sensation that if you
travel a lot you'll definitely have
experience before and it's one that can
be pretty perplexing because it forts
are typical understanding of reality
it's a sensation that tells us
acceleration isn't always felt and if
you've experienced it you'll know that
what resolves it his observation of the
surrounding environment this is because
once you see that the loading platform
or the station terminal is also moving
away from you you were much more
confident in your ability to say that it
is your train which is truly
accelerating and thus deduce that there
is a force acting on you that's the key
point
you must deduce where and how a force is
acting you never measure it force is
realized only through knowledge and
inference this makes it an epistemic
phenomenon as opposed to an ontological
one let's take another example you're in
a vehicle with an accelerometer when you
see the accelerometer move you can
conclude that the entire vehicle and
thus yourself is experiencing a force
you might be tempted to think this use
of an accelerometer constitutes an
objective measurement of experiencing a
force but this is not the case consider
instead that you're now in an empty room
with that same accelerometer and again
you see it move being that you don't
think it's probable the entire building
is experiencing a force you are more
likely to conclude there's a magnet
beyond the wall or some internal
mechanism of motion in your
accelerometer that is causing it's
sudden movement
these considerations point to the
conclusion that force is a
context-dependent phenomenon
you're already probably familiar with
this idea through centrifugal forces or
any other quote-unquote fake forces
which are coordinate dependent but
that's the subtle distinction that's
left out when real forces are discussed
all forces are initially coordinate
dependent what makes a force real or
absolute is determined after the fact
via global considerations we can make
this idea more precise consider an
object that accelerates relative to you
you can apply Newton's laws to determine
that it is experiencing a force but
here's the catch
Newton's laws are only valid if you are
certain your frame is inertial otherwise
it could be you who is accelerating
rendering the force acting on the object
a false
coordinate of one thus explicate in a
force requires two components one
observation of a materials acceleration
and two knowledge that your observer
frame is inertial but how do you know
that your observer frame is inertial
that's the tricky part because there's
no real prescription for determining the
inertial nosov a frame an inertial frame
is defined by the absence of external
forces but to ensure you aren't
experiencing external force means
measuring for forces around you but
measuring force first requires knowledge
that your frame is inertial which
requires measuring for forces you know
there's a circle or okay obviously that
won't work well there's a second less
precise method which is just observing
the majority of matter and energy around
you and making sure you're not
accelerating relative to that for
example when you spin in a circle all
the stars and universe spin relative to
you that's a pretty good sign that your
frame is not an inertial one and that
the centrifugal forces pulling your
limbs outwards aren't real thus to be
confident of the presence of a force
requires multiple observations not just
of whatever matter is experiencing the
acceleration but also of the surrounding
environment and it's
this is what so many people get wrong
about force they're taught to couple it
blindly to acceleration when in fact
these are two vastly different
phenomenon acceleration is measurable
and always relative to the observer
while force which hinges on one's
knowledge of the total system is
epistemic and inferred indirectly this
means you can never feel force not in
any sense of the word indeed the more
you examine force the less tangible it
becomes not only does the reality of it
differ widely based on context but one
entire fundamental force gravity was
shown by Einstein to be something else
altogether an emergent property of the
geometry of space-time quantum mechanics
meanwhile doesn't even bother with the
concept of force but even before modern
physics the ontological status of force
was already well being called into
question philosophers and physicists the
likes of Lazar a Carnot Gustav Kirchhoff
Henri Poincare a and others were so
bothered by the unobservable unreality
of force that they all independently
attempted to construct a framework for
classical mechanics that did not invoke
the concept of force but rather relied
on observables alone what bothered panca
Ray in particular was the idea of
associating force with causation as
Charles plateau al wrote and rational
mechanics force is only a human concept
and we have no knowledge of the profound
causes of motion it's as though force is
most truthfully a stand-in for what we
don't understand about the nature of
change
moreover the inability to define it
locally means that statements like the
one from the beginning of our video
which assert the local distinguished
ability of accelerated frames aren't
necessarily correct that means if force
and change are truly connected reality
might not be as objective as our
intuition tells us
after all there is no way truly feeling
force this has been dialect thanks for
watching
[Music]